hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
pe.l2-3.10.2 protect and monitor the
physical facility and support
infrastructure for organizational
systems
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone try to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 10171 compliance stuff
on top of an already colossal workload
well I've got great news for you you
found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it okay two things to break down here
physical facility uh and then there's
the support infrastructure all right two
different things two more things to
break down you have to do with them
protect them and monitor them to very
different things okay so a couple of
real life examples here I personally
think is very very very hard to
adequately monitor a physical facility
without having a camera system to do it
we were asked all the time uh why we
recommend camera systems uh when we're
putting together plans of actual
milestones for people and this is the
control where we look at it we go hey
look I don't know how else you could
really adequately monitor the physical
premise and look there's all kinds of
other great benefits to account camera
system like you know stopping theft
being able to ID people finding out if
you have tailgaters and things like that
I really can't emphasize you know look
it's really worth the investment you
don't have to go get a crazy expensive
one I mean heck they sell them for 200
on Amazon these days
so uh it doesn't have to cover
everything so there's another misnomer
okay camera system doesn't have to cover
everything but we we've used the litmus
test that the camera system really needs
to cover the entrances the exits and the
security sensitive areas which by the
way uh you determine as a company what
is a security sensitive area generally
speaking things like uh Network closets
or you know it rooms should definitely
have a camera on them and any kind of
really sensitive work areas where you're
dealing with cui uh you know again it's
up to the organization to be providing
adequate security and determine what
that means okay so there's some
flexibility here
short of that and I think it's pretty
tough to monitor the physical premise
okay protecting the physical facility is
a little easier you can do that with
locked doors and access control so the
protect part's not so bad but the
monitor part you gotta have camera
system uh and uh again lots of different
mechanisms for protecting right key fobs
door locks biometric locks you name it
all right do I think you can monitor and
protect the facility or the
infrastructure without a camera system
well tell me how in the comments below
if you think it's possible because uh
just because you have evidence of a key
fob access does not give you the ability
to monitor the building access control
is not monitoring okay let's see what
the assessors are looking for on this
one four things you're looking for one
determine if the physical facility where
organizational systems reside is
protected a couple ways we can do it we
can implement it via the physical
premise security system which may
include the dwarfobs an alarm system uh
you know a camera system although this
is all about determining if the physical
facility uh is actually protected so
cameras aren't going to protect they're
going to monitor but again it is it is a
deterrent so it does help assessment
Point number two determine if this if
the support infrastructure for
organizational systems is protected this
is implemented via the physical premise
security system physical access systems
uh again uh how is it protected again if
you've got a MAG lock on the door to the
server room really really tough to
really get through that thing same thing
uh in terms of uh you know the server
room and even a lock and key right if
there's a door there's a wall that's
pretty good uh pretty good
determine if the physical facility where
organizational systems resides is
monitored now this is again this is the
assessment point where I think it's so
hard to do this without a camera system
uh again our answer to it in fact is
implemented to be the physical premise
security system camera system all right
final assessment point is determine if
the support infrastructure for
organizational systems is monitored
again not just the physical facility but
now we're getting into the support
infrastructure like the server room
implemented via the physical private
security system and the camera system
specifically within it so again I think
we find that it's really hard to give
these answers without having a camera
system in place if you don't have a
camera system in your office keeping an
eye on things I highly recommend it
again it's just not that expensive
anymore you know even just a few years
ago it used to be really really
expensive to get one of those major
alarm companies actually give you a
working camera setup but these days it's
not so bad now uh if you're struggling
with this stuff if you can't figure it
out or if you have a day job which I
know you do and it's probably not
getting compliant the good news is that
in on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped in their laps like a seal
on a sunny day and we teach you how to
level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon so they have more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmccompliant secrets.com
or check out the bio below for links to
get help right now if you love the
content we're putting out here for you
help us out with a big thumbs up on that
like button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerds roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you